he's kind of like yeah
welcome back to this episode of trash
taste and with the boys as usual Jerry
and gone and today we have Felix
all of you in the comments can shut the
[ __ ] up now we got him six nine like we
promised
I don't want to know what episode this
is 120 something probably yeah we should
have just waited yeah yeah yeah it's uh
it's double of 69 probably yeah this is
like the build up since I think episode
one that's uh people have been asking
for you together really yeah yeah like
you're the goat so everyone's always
like oh okay okay now you guys are
hyping me up right away such a great guy
people just love you on your own
marriage yeah but thank you very much
for coming on and uh I guess this is a
late welcome to Japan because you've
been here for like over like a how long
have you been here now like a month yeah
we left when you got here yeah yeah it
was so fun like uh I was so excited to
finally come on trash hey meet you guys
and then uh you guys just to go
so much time to not go anywhere
yeah like how how has your Japan
experience been so far right again
pretty good having uh having a lot of
fun you're basically retired at this
point I feel like that's what everyone
says you're just like enjoying your
retirement in Japan now yeah well we
have a lot of you know chill to catch up
with yeah I feel like I'm doing more
stuff here than I've done like the last
three years in UK right well there's not
much to do yeah yeah
and even if you do drink in pubs it's
just like how many times have we cannot
drink in a pub and do something new you
know it's let's go to the next Pub yeah
to be very even Japanese people are like
you're doing more stuff than I've done
for us because they're working all day
yeah
I have to do this thing called work
well that's why I'm moving to Japan
right as a YouTuber it's like it's great
you get like The Best of Both Worlds you
get to enjoy the really cool Parts about
Japan without having to partake in the
normal uh work culture man life which is
notoriously one of the worst in the
world yeah that's really bad were you
always uh did you always have like a
fascination with Japan I can't remember
if you did or no no you came here once
and you were like yeah yeah it was uh my
wife might say we wanted to go and I was
like sure whatever and then
I've always been into anime but I never
had like a big obsession with Japan
right yeah yeah I feel it's just you're
probably just like we're you know
exposed to a lot of Japanese like
culture right like you know like
obviously the anime but also like just
the games and stuff like that so I feel
you kind of just like actually I feel
like everyone kind of yeah that's why
there's a lot of curiosity yeah
definitely definitely was that a point
where you came to Japan you're like [ __ ]
I can see myself yeah what was the
talking point yeah that was actually
four years ago something like that we
were here for a month and yeah after
that we were like damn we really don't
want to go home this is actually really
good was that the trip I mentioned
we used to come here every year and yeah
yeah we had that we'd stayed a little
longer like a month and then we were
just like damn it's actually really nice
so we had a meeting with people I'm like
oh how's the Visa gonna go and like they
were like like a couple months and then
we're good we're like okay great so we
were planning our wedding at the same
time yeah and we were like okay let's
keep we're gonna make this work we're
gonna do it as fast as possible and then
yeah obviously Kobe hit in two years I
think three years three years to close
to three years yeah it was pretty brutal
yeah yeah it was not fun
but now I'm here yeah
and no one else can understand I was
gonna say honestly everyone pretty
thought that you just like did it on a
whim I feel like in someone said YouTube
what does he get to go in I I've been
trying to go in for the past two years
uh maybe I don't know like
it took a long time but we didn't really
talk about it yeah I was so [ __ ]
pissed off having to wait too and I was
just so mad but I was trying to hold it
in because I didn't want to be entitled
about entering the country but it was
yeah it was rough yeah because people
are very picky about it and they're
really like it yeah oh yeah you have to
deserve to come to you yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you can't just like anime and play
Nintendo you don't really enjoy that's
the problem if you do only like anime
and you want to go to Japan
with tourists to go to Japan we don't
warn you here yeah well because the
thing is like you were waiting for two
years to come in Japan I think we were
wasting two years to leave
first opportunity we're like all right
yeah but like now that we're now that
we're back like I've really really
missed a lot of like little things in
Japan
traveling out there I can't imagine how
it's been for you just like experiencing
just living here for the first time for
the first four months has there been
like any like different different like
little things that you've noticed living
here that you've really enjoyed and
maybe some things that you haven't uh
and there's a lot of [ __ ] paperwork
someone understands the pain yeah but we
got a taste of that before obviously
yeah Visa you kind of realize Jesus
Christ I had to resubmit it three times
as well because it kept expiring and so
it's like redo all the papers and yeah
but even like getting uh Edgar River
salads oh my God that sounded like yeah
I mean you have to ran out of [ __ ]
private jet for that yeah we did get it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's a real
Alpha move yeah
I I actually we we thought about it
quite early like okay how can we make
this easier to bring our dogs over
because it was such a hassle yeah and
then Martin proposed like getting a
private time I was like no [ __ ] way
I'm paying
why would I ever do that that's so
stupid but then the whole process is so
complicated and that might not make
something easy yeah my dog was one kilo
over overweight for all the airlines in
the entire world like it's what I've
called every Airline ever no there's one
airline that was like it's okay but if
uh people have a falcon on board then
you can't go
a falcon yes I'm like uh Eastern
countries they prioritize Falcons on the
what
like what are these roles
on top gets first here do you know how
it is I mean you know yeah you put them
in a pen we'll see what happens
you know you have this two chickens
I'm not rolling the dice on the Falcon I
like how they're just like Falcon's
pretty sick though
like I was specifically a falcon yeah
out of everything no other Predator how
many people are transporting Falcons out
there in the world they have a lot of
Falcons but uh yeah it's um we didn't
risk that and then yeah my dog was one
killer too too fat and we had already
died to him once it was really Slim and
ready for the flight but then obviously
everything got delayed was was there a
part of you that didn't want to tell
YouTube that you got a private jet
because you didn't want to deal with
people being like Oh I didn't get a
privilege yes well because people I feel
so a little bit weird about that you
know being like oh he's just trying to
[ __ ] it's like it's like how much do you
have to pretend like you don't have
money
you know what I mean I just don't like
the whole like for the environmental
reasons I guess that felt a little bit
shitty but like we had a decent I mean
you're not Elon Musk taking a nine
minute chat ride so I feel like that's
you know you took one of the longest
possible rides you could have I'm not
trying to justify it for you hey it was
a good purchase
quite frankly I mean yeah it was pretty
cool
I would do exactly the same yeah
I'll allow it yeah they're basically are
children
I'd do it for my kids yeah I wouldn't do
it for my kids really doctor maybe yeah
I would say I would do it for my kids
but actually it would just be for me
yeah yeah sure sure the tier list goes
Falcon Dog Adventures
kids are so prioritized even like the
dog has to weigh a certain amount of
kilos yeah my dog was too fat that's why
we had to take the kids
how much is that child weigh
so why the dollars yeah it is weird yeah
oh yeah I never thought about it like
that because I've never had to transport
animals uh thank
no kids
please
prefer to see it next to a dawn I would
a hundred percent if that was an option
in my flight I would take that every
time crying baby versus dog of course of
course I'm gonna pick the dog every time
you know definitely very true very true
I mean I'm sure we've all had enough
experience with flights where there's
just that one kid that just oh my God
explained the kid though I'm like ah
they you know it's like the kid decided
you know what I'm gonna [ __ ] with
everyone today I'm gonna cry they do no
I'm like
I'm like we're out of the jurisdiction
right I can get away from it honestly we
have our international waters yeah yeah
well like the babies I can understand
because you know no con yeah they can't
control but sometimes when they there
are some kids that are like three or
four and their parents just like let
them do whatever they oh my God that's
the ones that really like grind my gears
yeah I don't think kids should be in
business class I don't think they've
earned it you know I just don't who if I
say kids in business
I went on the business class and there's
two kids had their own seat and I'm like
you mother yeah
even if I was a billionaire I'm putting
my kid in the worst economy seat at
least right
he's not going to appreciate the
business
I just I just
is not going to appreciate it no no why
would you I don't care how rich you are
or either that or the kid's gonna get
used to it wow you got the [ __ ] you got
the small seats like a [ __ ] peasant
but when you're a kid just going on a
flight it's fun enough yeah like did you
just give that kid a Game Boy oh so wow
that's not appropriate for the times
anything that runs Minecraft and he'll
be fine yeah sure sure yeah because
we're getting to the points now where
Wi-Fi is starting to be used on flights
and to me that's so alien and I don't
like it I like being it's also [ __ ] huh
yeah
it is [ __ ] I think we'll get to the
point where it's gonna get become yeah
you're right become usable Extreme
videos and at that point I'm like I kind
of like going on a flight and just
feeling like you're completely
disconnected and I'm gonna be that old
guy who is like all things were better
when you're gonna use internet yeah also
remember downloading the entire library
of Netflix on my phone so I can not
watch it I feel like there's like gonna
be some level of like Nostalgia to it as
well because it's a very like novel
thing where it's like you know like the
airplane movie experience it's like you
know we're going to be there Generations
like back in our day so we had to look
at adjacency film for this small
do you guys remember when they changed
the rules so that you can finally
[ __ ] use your or whatever electronic
device
because you have to you have to tone it
off when did they change it when
airplane mode was invented on like no no
it was not that long ago really yeah
pretty recently yeah and it was like the
greatest change of all time because
every time why do I have to put it away
yeah or even some like flights they
still like make you put it away or they
still announce that you're not allowed
to use it what the [ __ ] can't do
anything yeah and then nobody just
listens yeah like they're like I'd be on
my phone and then like a student will
walk after me and be like oh excuse me
you have to take you have to put that
hasn't happened to me it happened to me
once she was like you have to put your
phone I still do that and I was like oh
okay and I put in my pocket she walked
off
as anyone would do yeah
what a terrorist Jesus Christ
because I'm walking around and no one's
following it everyone's doing the exact
same thing because it's like it's one of
other people do it you think it's okay
yeah did you ever think where like
recently I think some of the planes to
have it so that when you if you leave
your mobile data on or something like
the phone knows somehow that you're on a
plane and it turns into like plain
something oh it's okay to some data but
it's like the plane it's really weird I
don't know what this is I've never used
I'm never gonna make a call yeah I do
not want to make a call on a flight yeah
I'm not that much of a businessman no no
I don't know too lazy would you say then
you're still like on your honeymoon
phase in Japan or is the reality kind of
slowly starting to sing in the reality
the reality what is the reality the
reality holes like Japan is cool but
it's not like it's always me yeah you
have to Surf every week oh no yeah uh
yeah I mean we kept thinking it would I
think we actually had a different
sorry to experience with the first month
we were like oh [ __ ] we actually like
reset everything yeah and now we kind of
have a lot of [ __ ] to do to
kind of get there's always something
yeah and there was a lot and we kind of
It kind of stressed me out a bit I was
like oh damn that's actually not like
it's not food it's not just like a
roller coaster right away yeah yeah I
think uh we just settle in more and more
and more and now we've been here four
months so we're still really really
enjoy it yeah it's really fun that's
good but I do think I mean obviously
like yeah I don't know because I because
I remember the when when you finally
announced that you were gonna you and
Marty were gonna be moving here yeah and
just like on on your videos just the
amount of comments you probably got of
like well Japan's not that great of a
country do you know all of these
statistics
weird about Japan yeah yeah they're
really weird and it's like only Japan I
feel because like if you were like oh
I'm moving to you know the UK people
won't be like well did you know all
these stats in the UK it's like why is
it only Japan that is like put up on
this like golden platform of Standards
people either idolize it or they hate it
yeah there's no in between yeah that's
true yeah it does feel like especially
on the internet I don't know if it's
just on the Internet or with like
everyone but people like Japan has like
this really weird image of just being
like things that come from Japan are
very like I think is that Meme of that
guy being like thing thing from Japan
yeah but like yeah it's pretty [ __ ]
right I mean
there are a lot of things you're like
actually this is pretty [ __ ] sick and
other times you're like yeah it's
liberated I I don't know like when you
see videos of like did you guys know
they still use fax machines it's like
all right okay all right thanks for that
I mean yeah cool I get it not gonna make
my life easier yeah yeah even just going
to like uh what is it called optician
yeah yeah it went here and it was such a
streamlined quick experience yeah in UK
is [ __ ] awful oh yeah oh really yeah
yeah everything to do with Healthcare in
the UK it just takes it was forever yeah
I don't know I thought it would have
been the opposite I don't know I don't
know because it was like want to spoke
English really well no it's pretty bad I
found a dentist here that's like fluent
English they do everything like an
American would and it was great it was
better than I ever had in the UK yeah
yeah they were like we're gonna remove
everything and redo to your teeth we're
gonna fix it all right I had like a
filling from the UK right
and they used Mercury and Mercury for my
filling so it's like a black filling and
people what it was a really old style of
filling just trying to like mercury
poison you well you know the UK is very
up to date with dental practice no it
was it was like an old thing they used
to do for some reason I guess in Wales
kept doing it they just did it when I
was a kid it's like the thing in Dune
where it like crunches down and explodes
it genuinely felt like when I found out
that because I didn't know it was
Mercury this entire time I was just like
I had a filling and then the the dentist
was like yeah you got a Mercury a
Mercury feeling what and she's like you
want me to like just take it out and
I'll just put one in right now that's
good and I was like oh yeah it was like
done in like 20 minutes it's awesome
what the [ __ ] in the UK have to make a
booking come back in seven months yeah
and then they'd be like oh we canceled
your booking because you didn't reply to
our email two days ago they went in spam
dang thing Japan it's true yeah I think
there's a little bit of Truth
is there anything that you thought was
going to be good that was [ __ ] uh
uh was it all been uh [ __ ] [ __ ] um not
to your expectation I guess like a lot
where you were saying about people
comments in in the beginning a lot of
people are kind of like oh yeah did you
know this and that and so I was kind of
like tensed up when I was going to be in
those situations like people say old
people are really racist and whatever
I'm not sure yeah it's like yeah it's
like any country every old every country
is racist old people yeah exactly yeah
yeah so yeah one meeting in like all the
neighbors we were just like oh God are
they gonna hate us they're just gonna
yell at us but yeah and then they were
lovely and you feel like [ __ ] free yeah
I guess so yeah I mean I actually had to
make a conscious choice to like just let
my own experience dictate what yeah he's
gonna be here because yeah there is so
many people saying stuff about
everything I mean when I always try to
say hi to my elderly uh I mean yeah
they were not they were not no they were
definitely yeah
oh that's probably because of you that's
funny they show me they're like damn I
thought it was Felix
so I got him back I got them back I put
vegetable oil at their their front door
no just don't get just don't take your
garbage out on the wrong day that's it
that's it like if you want a speed run
getting hated by your neighbors it's
it's garbage out on the wrong yeah I
know that and I've been terrified of
that and I've been so careful every time
like checking my garbage and I there's
like a huge relief every time I see
they've taken it yeah no I I got the
exact same thing and then one time I
didn't they didn't take it yeah and I
was going to the supermarket and I
walked past and I saw a bin had a bag
hadn't been taken and I was like I hope
it's not mine it's not mine it's not
mine I walk to supermarket and I'm like
I should just go check it
so I know and it was [ __ ] mine
they did like a thing on it like a
plastic wrapper being like we did not
take this because it was not sorted
correctly and I was like no
sometimes I see other people do it wrong
and they leave it I'm like they're gonna
think it's me yeah
every time I put the garbage out when I
see the garbage uh that has been sorted
incorrectly I'm like I know they're
gonna blame it on me because I'm the
only four
have a conspiracy this is why living in
like an apartment complex is so op now
like everything you take the trash out
whenever you want you can take it to the
area's great oh it's great I used to
have to like make a giant Palace of
cardboard and take it out on the
cardboard yeah yeah yeah
but then they installed a security
camera in the cardboard place and I'm
like is it because of me did I do
something probably yeah
they're looking out for me although they
have a big sign saying security camera
oh wow in English
yeah oh no yeah they started putting out
signs at my place too and it hasn't been
signs for like two years
I wonder why they're starting to put out
instructions
man was it okay I don't know if this is
too personal to ask was it weird going
back to the house after you know
obviously got they got like robbed ages
no it wasn't weird no no I guess I was a
little paranoid people were gonna break
in again
but uh no no it wasn't weird plus they
didn't take anyone on my stuff too so
sorry
you're like damn this is [ __ ] easy
did they like really ever try and make
like an effort or was it just kind of
like yeah it sucks to suck man that's
just one of those crimes that doesn't
usually yeah yeah they give us tea at
the station that's great
that's all I needed
did it wait actually it happened when
you're out completely outside of Japan
right you couldn't come in uh uh when
did it happen what's the timeline ages
ago yeah it was like three years ago
right yeah I think two three years ago I
think it was before covet actually so we
were able to come back in okay okay oh
sorry I thought you hadn't come back and
I was like that must be weird yeah you
confused me too now I was like wait I
don't know
uh yeah yeah we got that sorted but no
we didn't get anything back yeah of
course yeah are you gonna try and learn
Japanese when you're here I'm trying but
it's no
get ready get ready for the comments for
in like three years where they're like
yeah what do you mean you're not fluent
yeah and it's like ah if only that's how
it works three years more like three
months I I remember feely's tasted me
the other day being like what are you
doing and I'm like not much what about
you and he's like I'm learning kanji and
I want to die
yeah it's pretty bad I was just like yep
sounds about right Japanese is
definitely one of those things for that
the first the more you study the more
you realize how [ __ ] you are at it yeah
yeah how much more of a challenge it is
yeah because it's like that perfect I
don't know what the curve is called
right but yeah like just the learning
curve learning curve well like it's like
confidence versus knowledge and it's
like you learn cat's gonna hear a gun
yeah you're like [ __ ] yeah
three alphabets done
I am never going to learn Japanese till
the day I die man for getting there
slowly surely yeah yeah you're doing
like online lessons or are you just yeah
I'm teaching yourself self learning yeah
very satisfying when you finally like
have a conversation that doesn't go at
all badly you're like wow I said
everything correctly and I understood
everything which is great I'm fluent and
then someone says something else later
you're like I hate my life anything I
remember Aki was saying like the number
one thing that made her like really
happy was when she walked outside and
then the one sign she couldn't read
suddenly it was just like I know what
that means now yeah it's cool I've seen
that before yeah
yeah I remember when you guys a couple
of years ago you were talking about like
Jewel zoo and like how you get it all
the time you especially tell me like
don't worry you'll get it all the time
for links yeah and then I come here and
I practice a lot and I'm like
where's my [ __ ] joke
you haven't got it yet no but you took
like a couple weeks and then I was
chatting with my neighbor and then all
of a sudden she's like oh no I feel I
was just like I feel like they're like
sometimes they chose you and they're
like I don't know what else you want me
to say yeah [ __ ] you Japanese is good by
the way by the way yeah I've noticed
it's much harder to get josu in Tokyo
but as soon as like do you travel
outside of Tokyo
like ryokan or something like I
literally I came back just from hakadate
and I got Josie more in hakadate than my
entire year in Tokyo oh yeah because
everyone's just like what what you can
speak just a little bit of Japanese with
I think it's Tokyo and like he's a
foreigner he's probably he could
probably say like a few words you know
and it's not even like something that
impressive either you could just like go
up to a store and be like konnichiwa and
they'd be like I'm going to Joseph I'm
just saying thanks
another one I'm counting them damn sorry
I'm sorry I lied to you then because you
haven't had it a lot no no no it happens
all the time
it'll come Felix okay okay thank you I'm
still waiting but like do you guys say
to people that speak good English then
yeah I do
I say it ironically but I don't think
they take it ironically yeah yeah we
feel like very good English then the
Japanese person will be like oh thank
you
yeah I don't speak any English and then
they stop talking and they speak pretty
good English and you're like bro what
the [ __ ] your English is like good you
could live a humble Japanese people I
know right I know it just annoys me yeah
like I feel like I've met more good
speaking English like good Japanese
speaking
I'm confused because you can speak good
English people who speak in English well
obviously better than me
than I have like foreigners that can
speak good Japanese oh yeah especially a
lot of Japanese people who do speak
English or are you know trying to learn
it a very uh very eager to speak it so
they come up to you and they start
speaking they're normally really nice
that's really cool because I think it's
also the whole thing of like you know
Japanese people they they don't know how
to be like cocky or like overconfident
with their skills so the only thing they
can do is undersell themselves even
though they might be like [ __ ]
amazing at it but that just annoys the
other person even more it is a bit
annoying
but like I do notice when because they
want us to practice their English uh
they always try to speak English to you
but I want to practice my Japanese so I
had this like awkward taxi ride the
other day I had this awkward taxi ride
the other day where you know we go in
and the taxi driver tries his best to
answer us uh ask us stuff in English so
I got an entity driver he asks oh oh
where do you want to go and I'm like I
answered in Japanese I'm like here's my
address
and can I take the highway please and
then it's like a battle because even
though I was speaking Japanese he would
reply to me in English I would enter and
reply in Japanese so we ask uh like he
asks uh temperature uh oh okay and I I
would like reply yes the temperature is
fine it's the most like no you bad I'm
like please speak Japanese to me I'm
trying to price my Japanese like no
you're both doing it though yeah yeah
he's like who's gonna fold first
it's like I will not fall I will fight
yeah I love it but yeah like it's uh
it's you know one of the best places to
get practice for your Japanese honestly
like taxi drivers I'm just going out
going out to bars
that's like one of the best places to
get the confidence tune yeah because you
drink and you're like oh I'm gonna make
so many mistakes but then everyone else
is really chill yeah everyone loosens up
a bit it's really good yeah yeah when
you're drunk just like your
embarrassment levels just go down so
you're just like not afraid to make
mistakes then you learn way more than
yeah yeah you hesitate way too much oh
yeah say this again have you been in
have you been enjoying the nightlife
much in Japan uh nightlife no because my
dog is demented so we can't do anything
at night usually oh no but yeah yeah she
gets crazy at night basically yeah so
are you retired or retired yeah I think
that's the biggest question all of your
fans have yeah they actually retired
I've said it years ago because I I think
I had done it 10 years at the time yeah
and I was just thinking like
I don't know if it's like a middle-aged
crisis or something or maybe just
mid-life yeah like you're 30. I've done
this 10 years and I'm just like do I
want to keep doing it at this pace for
like another 10 years and I was like
yeah [ __ ] no so yeah I just made a
conscious choice to just like
focus more on what so you're like
enjoying my retired yeah I mean I guess
I had the choice of like oh do I want to
quit or do you want to if you didn't
enjoy making videos yeah I presume you
would stall exactly and I still enjoy it
but I don't like the pressure that you
kind of put onto yourself and I am
always chasing the algorithm and doing
whatever like people want so yeah just
doing what I like and focusing on that I
feel like why not like why make it and I
feel like you're past like 10 years as
well like it's been just an absolutely
[ __ ] insane it's been a [ __ ] ride
yeah yeah like you've done so many
you've done so much [ __ ] in such a short
span of time where it's just like I'm
good now yeah yeah I don't blame you man
you guys are like in the midst of it it
seems like nothing so busy I think so
piece of advice do you have then from uh
have former person already okay enjoy it
well you can [ __ ] it I want to have my
dream hack uh
where I go on stage and sing why have
you seen that I love that question I
love that clip
no I haven't seen this yes I'm so sorry
okay
this is like early early YouTube
this is like my favorite clip I'm glad
you enjoyed it it's so good I don't know
why like maybe you guys can relate to
like just thinking yeah yeah that's fine
I can do that because they like they I
feel like sometimes they put your idea
or there's an idea gets said you're like
yeah sure and then you don't actually
think about it
and you're like this was a horrible idea
I didn't even think it was a horrible
idea like yeah okay so uh I had done
YouTube for like a year it doesn't
matter but there's a convention like a
land big land party right yeah I guess
it's pretty famous now yeah
um and they have a stage and they were
like do you want to come to dreamhack
and like play games on stage and I was
like yeah sure all right absolutely like
oh recognition by someone that's awesome
yeah and I had nothing planned and at
the time I uh played like Happy Wheels
and I sang karaoke and I thought that
was like the funniest [ __ ] ever I mean
it was pretty funny
and then I was like [ __ ] what do I do on
stage I have no nothing prepared like I
just had my laptop they're like all
right cool you've already left up go on
stage here you go entertain these people
and I was just like all right I guess we
play some happy wheels that was fine and
then if for some reason I thought like
playing karaoke was gonna be a good idea
so I sang on stage what did you see uh
take on me oh my God
and it's just a clip of uh it's a nice
clip of me it's good it's just funny
because I'm like singing and I'm into
like take on me it's just terrible you
cut to the audience and they're just
like
I think I think every single YouTuber
needs a moment like that so it's like
you just you just I don't know why like
I cringe it's so much [ __ ] I do but for
some reason that to me is just funny
like that's it's funny it's great how
long ago was this uh it must have been
10 years ago
stuff like that is where you look back
on you like that was the funniest [ __ ]
yeah that happened I think it's like I
had a great time doing that I actually
really enjoyed that day and it's a good
memory and that's just how I kept it in
my bank but even though it's not like
what it was it was right right pretty
painful but yeah hey I'll take the good
memory I mean
I really appreciate it I felt bad
Anthony I brought up the Smosh movie as
well and I felt bad that was classic I
was like I felt bad I was like it was
bad [ __ ] yeah I didn't see that Ninja on
we have to like bring about bring out
like the [ __ ] what did he do like
fortnite yeah I mean yeah that was my
fortnite floss movement
it's one of those when you're like young
YouTuber and you just like someone asks
you to do [ __ ] and you're like yeah yeah
I can do that it's like you're the
you're the big YouTuber company tells
you you should go do this thing because
we don't really understand it but we
know you're a big deal Go on stage
are you guys going on tour we are yeah
so hoping we don't have a moment
yes please do it if we do a Sweden tour
we'll do it oh yeah
are you going no you're in America
that's right yeah yeah maybe one day
maybe one day we'll do a Europe tour and
everything hopefully cool have you done
have you done like a live tour no no no
no luckily I have not done that I've
only done like ever one signing tour for
my book which is fun but no nothing did
you ever would you ever want to no [ __ ]
that when Jack Jack spoke so highly of
the idea and was like yeah I love
touring yeah I think he just he had a
good experience yeah yeah yeah really
good frame yeah yeah because he like he
said once he started Touring that was
like that was it for him he wanted to do
nothing else but tour compared to like
doing YouTube I guess people are
different some people respond more to
having a direct feedback from an
audience and yeah really enjoy that you
get sold on that I'm like yeah stay away
yeah I got that by the way it's nice to
know that there is a fellow Pizza
crosstalk all this podcast
how did you survive Italy like how did
that like what happened no one cares no
Italians they do they do care they do
stupid hotels you're walking out of the
restaurant they're just doing this you
just didn't realize it these [ __ ]
foreigners I remember so because the
thing is I always eat pizza with a knife
and fork yeah
come on come on actually do you think
Felix Felix yeah
if it's like I do it if it's a really
really good pizza right not not Domino's
if it's like Stone baked you know I I
would prefer to eat with a knife and
fork yeah honestly because it spills
less over exactly and you can choose
like the exact piece that you want to
like buy every time and it's it's
awesome it's all those perfect pieces
are slicing up the pizzas like taking I
don't know how long no it comes with
proceeding right away no no no okay
most pizza places cutting the pizza
Italy every time I went to Italy they
would always give you the pizza uncut
and it pissed me off so much like hey
[ __ ] off
what's up with that why do they do that
I don't know [ __ ] I don't know maybe
forward that question I remember I
thought it was normal to eat with the
knife and fork pizza and then I remember
because I I always get every time I go
eat pizza with people I've had to like
condition myself if it's like new people
I like okay I'll play on YouTube
I'll eat the crust and I'll like slice
it and then like pick it up the enemy
stand will try to fit in guys okay
judgment I remember the first time I
thought it was normal like I ate in UK
and then I'm I'm just like enjoying my
pizza and then I look up and everyone's
like staring at me I might as well
killed someone like what's the problem
it's like a Russian Squad
what the [ __ ] are you doing
I'm enjoying my pizza yeah it's the way
God intended exactly exactly I've had to
like this is how you know you if you're
good friends with me is if I eat a pizza
with a knife and fork in front of you
that's how you know because that's that
means I don't give a [ __ ] about you yeah
I am comfortable I I do not need to
conform to social norms if it's super
slopping it all just falls off then yeah
I mean you have no choice because you
otherwise I would get like a fork to
kind of like scoop it yeah I do that as
well like I wouldn't do use the knife no
no I use it as a leverage if it turns
into a soup one I pick it up I guess I
have no choice yeah that's why we never
had the problem yeah okay how do you
calzone then
were you gonna pick up a calzone that's
monstrous that's the point eating a
piece of a knife and fork you basically
just like turn into your basically quite
a calzone to the pizza in that sense
it's not it kind of is because you're
like it's it's just a wrapped up piece
it's just a different dishes
I'm sure you could but it would look
weird
people eating with their hands
would you be a hot dog with a knife
and
forks
chili dog is [ __ ] Messy as [ __ ]
sometimes I don't want to get all that
[ __ ] on my hands man no [ __ ] no that
that's the fun part that's how you know
it's a good hearty meal when it's like
messy you don't need a [ __ ] Taco we
have civilization for a reason Jerry
sometimes you eat a taco with a knife
and fork why are you talking no no
that's just ridiculous
you can't equate a chili dog to a taco
that's completely different like levels
like chili dogs are like way more
messier than the taco that's part of the
tacos are like nice
they're like perfectly hand-sized a
chili dog like a good chili dog will
like spill everywhere you know it's it's
the ratio there's way more there's
there's way more chili episode
hot food tanks we try not to do this
every day yeah yeah you're a boneless or
bone-in chicken guy I gotta asked just
to make sure eat chicken because I'm
gonna die but boneless thank you
yeah me too me too I don't know why
though I guess it's these it's just easy
I don't want to deal with this bone [ __ ]
I remember when Felix first said that he
was an epic pescetarian I was like is
that like a different level of
pescatarian it is I'm better than
everyone when did you become a
pescatarian uh
forever ago well because vegetarian
right yeah yeah and I couldn't I didn't
want to commence
I like meat so much it's so hard
there's a lot of fake chicken that
tastes the same yeah but really really
where everywhere and the grocery store
you can buy it yeah does it and it taste
the time it tastes the same was it
because you haven't had it in so long
you're like this is honestly it tastes
the same okay okay I I think the thing I
can't get over
um that will always taste weird for me
is like vegan cheese like I've had very
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's never again I'm
telling you halloumi cheese is the best
it's like yeah you find a good vegan
pizza that's rare it doesn't happen I do
like vegan Burgers actually vegan
burgers are really good yeah you can get
some really good ones yeah I agree um we
went to a vegan place that was okay we
had vegan burrito yes that's right yeah
this is pretty good they put coriander
in it oh yeah [ __ ] you don't like
corianders why is that like a weird
thing everyone gets quiet
I think too much coriander is yeah I
mean it's genetic right if you like
coriander or not I think apparently but
I feel like people is it yeah
you can get a DNA test and in the DNA
test it'll tell you if you're more
likely you're less likely to like I
don't like ketchup that's that's genetic
no no no no no no no no no
like at all like mustard not actually
actually Japan has changed me because
like mayonnaise [ __ ] light no it
hasn't I still don't eat [ __ ]
condiments
not too much but I like it you know it's
like keeping mayonnaise just like I've
realized that it's just like the
superior mayonnaise of course you like
the mayonnaise here
yes what was that what the [ __ ] was that
what was that how the [ __ ] was that what
was that
it was like I'm gonna say something
I I haven't gotten used to it yet what
the [ __ ] what do you mean you like the
UK mayonnaise so creamy I'm not yeah
that's what makes it good you like the
watery ass like I want them like this
Bluey
that's what I'm using the one that plops
on okay so I'm not sure all right
another another Japan Centric question
obviously con beanies right everyone we
all love them yeah what's your go-to
food in in combini the onigiri which
which one tuna yeah it's pretty nice you
can't go wrong with it yeah especially
when they like actually when you get the
one in three on a giri where they
actually balance all the ingredients
well because I feel like two out of
three times you get it you're like I've
had four bites of rice yeah it's always
like or it's just like
it's like there's no tuna in this I'm
dying
I don't know yeah I love the egg and uh
tuna sandwiches egg and tuna it's like
uh half tuna half egg have you met how
you missed this what sandwiches are so
disgusting in UK okay
what which ones wait have you had a
Tesco meal deal with any of those well
you know I haven't that yeah that's why
I'm asking
how long did you live in the
UK's message
me and he's like he's like how was the
Tesco meal deal I'm like yeah it's
pretty good and then I gave him the
selection and I'm like what do you do
you rate my selection I feel this is
like I've never had it so I don't know
sandwiches
I've tried it once and they were just
not so this is this one sandwich from
this one mysterious [ __ ] place and
you've written off the entire country of
sandwiches have you ever been wait did
you ever go to Greg's
oh my God what were you doing for like
eight years I don't know what did you
eat okay tell me what you eat right now
in the UK what did you go to you know
what take a private jet out loud
it looks so bad you know I feel like
people would be more receptive if you
like I never want to speak English in
the UK fine I will never try Greg's what
sausage rolls don't taste like okay no I
I forgive you on that because I think
that it's where it's the it's the bakes
where it's all at the you know the the
bean cheese and sausage
my go-to my go-to order at Greg's is
like I might have a tricky sausage roll
but I'll normally get such a cheeky
sausages
gotta get maybe I'll get three and
either I get two cheese and onion
pasties I [ __ ] love the cheese oh
I'll get to uh cheese uh beans and
sausage when do you enjoy this it's like
a hangover food it's got to hang our
food if I'm feeling like I gotta you
know get back in touch with my UK Roots
you're on the roads you're taking a road
trip you stop at uh everywhere because I
like going to Japan and never having
sushi or something or it's like never
going to like uh
yeah
wait what did you eat when you were in
the UK honestly I was so confused for
the longest time like what the [ __ ] do
people eat
I don't what do you mean whatever you
guys talking about the meal that I'm
like oh so that's what people do a lot
of services
I don't get it Marsha Cooks but a lot of
times we go and I'm like what the [ __ ]
this takes forever
there's a genuinely like a few months
back there's an article being like uh
doctors were like begging Tescos and
stuff to stop doing meal deals was so
cheap yeah because they're so bad
they're so bad for you and that people
were buying them like every single day
for lunch because you get like it's all
processed and you know you get a bag of
crisps or something as well so it's not
good but man with value there yes three
pound if you have a Tesco Club card now
but three pound fifty you get a big
sandwich a big bag of crisps or fruit or
whatever and you get like a premium
drink you know one of the like not just
not just water well you can get like the
innocent smoothies you ever drink those
oh those are good you get like an
innocent smoothie in your thing and
those are like three pounds on their own
normally it's a joke yeah so you can get
that in the real deal I guess I've
missed that out okay
what fast food places or anything did
you eat out or never uh we should get
uh this is like I feel like I'm asking
Bill Gates the price of chicken nuggets
tell me
yeah she's Italian she likes security
okay
yeah I guess we do it's uh it's just
decent yeah it's pretty with the better
out of all of this
or anything like that well they have in
the UK delivery right yeah delivery yeah
yeah it's it's good there is now an
obsession with uh Japanese food in the
UK you might like there's all the
Japanese chains popping up oh really
yeah E2 uh Wasabi um
is like UK style yeah Wasabi has some
okay stuff like if you if you're craving
that Sushi it's like not bad but
obviously compared to Japan yeah yeah
yeah I love these restaurant names by
the way yeah
it's a little like so service level I
went to Japan once yeah yeah wagamama
shellfish
yeah what's that what it's called so
that's the what's that [ __ ] that's the
Marine Place yeah that's pretty decent
yeah what's the one everyone's obsessed
with that vegan place what's the one
vegan place everyone's obsessed with I
always see lines for it's red and it's
like a one word [ __ ] um yes yes
um what's it called I don't know what
you liked about oh you've seen them
everywhere what is it called it's gonna
drive me I didn't even know there was a
vegan chain so no
saw a vegan chain fast food UK it's
gonna come out right away
uh it did not come right away
[ __ ] this episode of trash taste is
sponsored by athletic greens guys I just
got back from my America Tour and as you
can imagine my body is not in the best
of shape right now that's why I started
using ag1 from our partners at athletic
greens with just one delicious scoop of
ag1 you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Foods sauce
ingredients probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right and one of
the best things is it's extremely
lifestyle friendly whether you eat keto
paleo vegan dairy free gluten free or
whatever because guys right now so many
people are taking some kind of
multivitamin so it's important to choose
one with high quality ingredients that
your body will actually absorb right now
it's time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs for your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com trash taste again
that is athleticgreens.com trash taste
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
Insurance God it was Leon
yeah Leon is what I'm saying about well
they have a lot of vegan options but
it's not exclusively vegan I was wrong I
thought it was because I only ever saw
vegan stuff on the menu but I guess
there's chicken stuff maybe they added
more yeah but it's pretty popular I know
in the UK this yeah
it's really good yeah on all the UK
vloggers always talk about how they love
really yeah how lovely aren't so lit
trying the one pound a day challenge
I love that video
so glad you got that
see this video yeah this is who did it
again was it Charlie days Charlie day
that's it
yeah
this is oh my God it's so hard to
survive on one pound
um how am I gonna do this oh my God
like a wave of memories that was that
was an interesting era yeah what do you
think of Brighton since you lived there
for a long time yeah I've got asked
because now I'm like I'm like because
like I I Joey was like you met Garn
right and I was like no I never met
going what are you talking about
and then in my ret tonight I have like
an image of you like far away and then
he's like no you shook hands I'm like
and then I listen there's so many
episodes of this [ __ ] podcast and
then you'd all of a sudden drop like oh
yeah my hometown bright and I'm like
Brighton
oh [ __ ] I've seen God yeah you literally
you literally came to pick me and knock
you out from his house yeah actually it
was it was funny because I met Felix for
the first time like two three weeks ago
and Felix like oh Joey said we met and
I'm like no we haven't yeah
Joey's just making [ __ ] up why would he
say that I've never met you
and then we shook hands I don't like
yeah Joey's such a liar we're in like
the lift or something and then Felix was
like yeah he was saying like I went to
your house or something and I was like
it was funny uh yeah we kind of randomly
just moved to Brighton yeah because you
stayed there for a while yeah it was
kind of like the YouTuber Hub of the UK
right yeah yeah it doesn't really feel
like it anymore in a weird way yeah
because I left yeah because he left now
it's Japan it felt like when you know
the UK was at its peak of youtubing
the ukulele era yeah and then now it
doesn't really matter
and every UK vlogger had a ukulele that
they could play as well yeah that was
the good old days it doesn't really feel
like UK has much YouTube stuff going on
yeah
they do they do like the sidemen are
like massive yeah I mean that that yeah
that those are those those guys are
massive YouTubers are [ __ ] their
pants because it's PewDiePie's here oh
yeah come and take over everyone yeah
you're not the biggest in Japan anymore
so yeah
well you seem to be enjoying doing your
Vlogs yeah it's really fun
it works I think it works because
YouTube is show like intense intense
intense I spent one billion dollars yeah
so I could get Mr BEAST's attention for
10 seconds I feel like though that
Style's almost coming back is like an
answer on YouTube right it's like
everyone like misses like the Nostalgia
of that kind of style of video it really
works though just feel bad for Chris you
know like Chris's put so much effort in
and then and then up comes Felix being
like yeah
top J vlogger in Japan sorry Chris
yeah my bad yeah Brighton I didn't want
to talk a little bit yeah yeah yeah
because um you grew up there yeah I grew
up there that's crazy and uh when I grew
up there it wasn't even a city it was
like a town like it was Brighton like
Brighton and hope were two separate
towns and then they were like what if we
like cheated the system and they just
murdered it and just merged it yeah it
makes no sense I'm like guys we are now
a city guys we were drawing a circle
around here don't worry it's a city now
that's happened a lot in the UK it's
happened a lot in the UK yeah a lot of
especially London a lot of the boroughs
and stuff change and they all merge and
stuff it happens a lot in the UK well
London a lot of Wars as well you know
yeah yeah that's true change the
landscape quite a lot like yeah what
made you want to move to Brighton
originally because uh growing growing up
yeah we were just lazy I guess well
London wasn't in your options no Elan is
too busy and then me and Marzia spoke
English to each other yeah right we're
like neither of us wanted to learn each
other's languages yeah let's go to UK
it's not too far away right it seems
cool it was yeah but then I think we
overstay our welcome a bit right yeah
yeah I'm sorry this is so windy and it's
great all the time it is it's almost
like the sea it just felt a bit
depressing after a while winter in
Brighton is just yes
because you just get battered by wind
and rain yeah I don't know if it's a
storm oh yeah [ __ ] time you didn't
want to uh you didn't want to move to
Wales
you went to where did you go in Wales
don't remember you went to like the
really weird Mediterranean looking oh
yeah that was cool yeah I remember I
posted photos of that and everyone from
Wales were like this is not my Wales
experience it's way too sunny and nice
we did get one week of sun we get one
week of Sunrise
I was like damn well this is actually
awesome yeah yeah it was really cool
thanks I'll take that to my grade yeah
I feel like it got cool after you moved
there because I grew up in Brighton
right and I did like my entire life I'm
like I can't wait to get out of the city
and suddenly you move here and then I
come I came back to visit like for the
past few years I'm like when the [ __ ]
did this city get so cool it's hustling
yeah it's hipster the city yeah there's
like so many good restaurants so many
hip places I'll wait for Pub crawling
exactly I was like where was this when I
was growing up oh really you didn't get
sick I didn't get that feeling
like it was like only cool during like
some months in the summer that was it
what was a good two thing to do in
Brandon growing up the beach oh yeah
that was it that was it that was not
barely a beach and that's you know
that's that's why like it's kind of like
Stockholm syndrome where I'm like Brian
has a good beach and I I'm like in my
heart in my heart I
think it's it's the best part right I
love it
either yeah I'm like I I will defend
Brighton Beach is a chill Place cool
place is it a good beach I don't know
probably not I mean Joey Joey comes
there from Sydney yeah he probably hates
it yeah I remember I remember when I
first went to go visit gone in Brighton
it was my first time in the UK ever and
God's like oh yeah we can have like the
weather's nice today so we can go down
to the beach I might sick all right I
like beaches let's go and I show up and
I'm like where is it
like where's the beach and he's like you
go all these rocks they're like sweet
can I go in the water nope
you can you can you can you just don't
want to just yeah it's kind of gross but
yeah it's yeah it's gross it's cold yeah
I took one look at the beach I'm like
I'm not going in that water I'm sorry I
have a girl it's fine yeah yeah you're
fine could you really enjoy it without
getting like recognized all the time
Beach is rough yeah yeah that's kind of
how it we felt like we enjoyed Japan a
lot because no one recognized it yeah
but British people are cool they're nice
I I like have you been recognized since
being here uh because there's not really
a lot of foreign
the train from London to Wales the
moment I go out of London I just get no
internet and I can't load anything and
it's like [ __ ] it's fun though I love it
I mean I I prefer the food in Wales to
like the rest of these you get really
fresh meat sorry they're fresh meat I
don't care
I'm just saying why did you just like
italicize me
no I I there's the pubs are like amazing
in Wales um if they have more pubs than
anywhere else in the world per like
square meter or something it's stupid
there's nothing else there it's nice
what's wrong
are they including Hove as well
pump up those numbers man yeah yeah we
got about 100
degrees
so so while there's no official stat it
is widely regarded speculated that
abovester is in Wales is home to the
most pubs per square mile in the UK most
pubscriber how many how many pubs Dragon
there is in a square mile square mile of
habitat yes damn it 50 no 50. originally
53 pubs per square mile isn't that
absurd that's more pubs than humans
everyone they're local this is where
you're going to get to as well it's like
the most West like middle thing because
everything's either North or South right
and then it's just here because you went
I'm in North North Wales yeah that's
where I'm from it's nice until certain
areas are not oh really it's nice yeah
it's gone yeah we like yeah I liked it a
lot where did you go in Wells because we
we asked Connor like if if you want to
go [ __ ] weird like how do you
remember them
it's almost like they're in a different
ways are they speak in another language
yeah
it's impossible to remember yeah yeah
every time an English person tells me
they went to Wales like a trip that like
I went to uh
yeah
it is funny driving through there and
seeing all the signs like there's no
[ __ ] way that's real there's no way
it's a fine language thank you very much
Ikea names there's no way that's real
I like to buy a vowel please okay that's
bothering I want to show you where you
where you went now I gotta remember the
name I mean you've been to quite a few
uh places where I like countries and
stuff like that like what would you say
is there like one place right now that
you really really want to go that's like
on the top of your bucket list because
other than Japan obviously ah Japan was
like big on our bucket list I think uh
going further away from Iceland oh he
kind of sucks a bit because that's a
really cool place to visit yeah we
really want to go that's why that's
number one yeah that's super fun I
really love Iceland yeah people think
I'm Icelandic too which makes me feel
like yeah
same fast internet Sweden they have the
same snacks as Sweden yeah from the
architecture it feels really nice check
out the comments to tell me where you
are but everyone's just like come to
Georgia it's better it's like what oh oh
yes yes
I know that place yeah I know we went up
north and around in a circle oh that's
good that's good there's some really
rough Parts up north really yeah oh yeah
people warned about that where they on
they don't speak English to you
let's do the historical stuff but like
yeah the north uh Northwest is the most
wall speakers out there oh okay but
they'll still speak English to you oh
okay I remember I tried to speak Russian
people and they were like no what yeah
they were like no they're the wrong
people I was like you betrayed me
yeah yeah it was cool Iceland's good
yeah
I don't want to go yeah it's it's like
weird that now that I've moved out I
hate how you two were literally right
[ __ ] next to it the entire time and
you're like bro I wish broke what do you
want me to do I had no money for so long
and I would I would not be able to buy
any food when I go out I'll be like I'll
go to the family listen I'm from
Australia which could be the polar
opposite of Iceland in terms of distance
yeah it's weird because now that I've
like moved out of Europe and the UK when
I was living there I just wanted to go
to Asia and I like traveled to Asia
everything on holiday and now I just
want to go back to Europe yeah and then
I did not take advantage of that yeah
when I was living there did you travel
Europe a lot it's like a kid with your
family because oh oh I did I did my
parents we did oh okay it was okay yeah
I don't know much
and but a lot of the places I'm like I
don't remember anything like I went to
Malta and I'm like I don't know what I
did yeah I don't know what happened in
Malta I remember is that everyone was
really like you couldn't negotiate a lot
on things oh yeah yeah and that's where
you get at the game boys with all the
games yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly [ __ ]
yeah yeah I remember Bulgaria as a kid
and that was very much like a this is
the price unless you can like haggle
with me yeah and yeah you get games that
were like definitely not real games
the Game Boy cartridges that had like a
hundred one thousand games one thousand
games in one cartridge I remember Army
this is back when DVDs like piracy was
like huge and you could just get like 20
billion DVDs for like one Euro oh it was
like Bulgaria and they were just like we
have nothing else to do take take 20
DVDs be like Spider-Man but only with
Bulgarian subtitles you know like well
it was it was 20 cents so uh what can
you do all those pirated games were so
[ __ ] dude
yeah of course yeah yeah yeah
I remember like you because all of the
101 pirated games you never heard of any
of these games no yeah and I'm just like
what is what is this game I've never
heard of it I've seen the hundred
thousand in one okay I've not seen that
those are good it's like 80 games and
they start looping oh yeah
that's good that was good and out of the
80 games it's like 30 of them are just
snake but re-skinned yeah yeah true true
snake was a good game yeah that's a good
game but like they would they would
purposely like name a different things
like super snake oh like Cobra do you
still gain much or is it not really that
much anymore uh uh I'm sure it's more on
like a casual sense right you call me
casual yeah you're a casual game Casual
Gamer yeah are you a normal gaming
I don't like to say it because I'm so
bad at Japanese still but I'm trying to
focus on that right now right
yeah I'm not a gamer right now I'm just
focusing on Japanese honestly yeah I'm
trying to I mean it makes sense how
about if you play the game in Japanese
yeah I've done that
how did I go
switched it back right away
which which game did you try to play I
did them for Valerian actually it was
kind of bad because the voice actors
changed it's kind of cool are you a
valentine player uh I did well Jack got
me into it oh and I also got really into
it and then he [ __ ] stopped playing
I'm like this [ __ ] he's like I
have now pushed the blame yeah
just sitting alone in lobbies with fives
[ __ ] strangers yelling at each other
I'm like why am I doing this this is
[ __ ] torture why am I playing this
are you playing much on the Japanese
servers or anything like that that's a
pretty good way to learn oh yeah it did
play a little bit of magic that was like
my introduction to Japanese Gamers
because they're so [ __ ] passive
aggressive oh yeah oh yeah bro they
don't all the emotes all the time I'm
like bro I haven't even done anything
yet I keep saying good game to me
they refuse to use mics a lot of the
time you have to like drag them onto the
mic they just won't like even in like
OverWatch or uh Apex Legends a dangerous
team yeah and everyone is like in
America you would just talk immediately
but in Japan it's like you really have
to like pry it out of them but sometimes
they're refunding it's possible to do
they're a lot more confident online real
life as well it is a different
anniversary yeah good way to try and
practice
yeah but like you know it's it's you're
learning you're probably learning some
words outside of the Apex game oh God
yeah yeah that you shouldn't use outside
of the Apes but you said it in real life
you'll be like oh God where'd you learn
that's like a good way to learn just
what are some like Japanese gamer terms
it's oh I forgot there was one there was
one that meant like swamp and it was
when you couldn't stop getcha pulling
yeah means like we're stuck in the swamp
basically when you're addicted yeah okay
yeah that was a good one um so it's like
when you're addicted to something you'd
say
you're in a sportsman you can't get out
there are some fun ones I think English
is way better for gaming terms yeah I
think we had much more fun terms I don't
know when they were explaining it to me
I don't know this game I don't know not
like because like I mean I think English
has better slang in general and
obviously that just translates to gaming
terms as well so yeah I mean I miss
gaming with you know English-speaking
people sometimes because
like I noticed as well Japanese people
are very passive aggressive and they
never get too involved but when they do
I don't know sometimes the passive
aggressive emotes they uh they trigger
me more than if someone just tells us
you know yeah I've seen Japanese Gamers
leave the game over like the smallest
thing it's so bizarre if you don't if
you like take an item they want it but
just immediately leave they're like [ __ ]
this yeah that's a dick move yeah damn
maybe I shouldn't took it but [ __ ] yeah
yeah I mean come on man that's when you
do the emote yeah
yeah have you tried watching anime
without subtitles then uh
doing that I feel like it helps with the
subtitles though like in Japan earlier
on earlier on yeah okay oh sorry I
watched English sometimes like I don't
know what the [ __ ] they're saying I need
subtitles I can't [ __ ] hear do you
watch much anime since coming here yeah
I'm watching yeah one piece right now
it's so good hell yeah hell yeah nice
it's really good so simony or something
absolutely whereabouts
giant Island oh giant Island okay oh
dinosaurs and [ __ ] yeah yeah it's really
yeah that's right I just got up to
reading oh really I'm just past that
past the same part there we are we are
all right yeah
it is good yeah I like it oh yeah we
started a really funny one but I don't
remember the name it's a recent one or
uh I think there's only one housewife
yaksa or something oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah wave of the house
it's on Netflix it's like [ __ ] animation
it looks like a manga it's like a
PowerPoint yeah I like that though yeah
the timing is so good the way they do it
yeah the acting in Japanese is on point
yeah that sounds really good I haven't
watched English but with the Japanese
one they were amazing there's like a lot
of people complain about that adaptation
when it came out because of oh really
the animation and also the manga has
like a hardcore fan base yeah Sakamoto
and if you like that it's oh yeah it's
like that but well animated and funny
yeah I think it's funny oh really
because I thought it was hilarious so
yeah you'll love it you'll love it it's
great yeah cool did you watch it like
just pure subtitles in Japanese or did
you I'm not that Jersey
well I I often find that actually I I
like at the beginning I tried to start
doing that and I'm like this is not
helping at all but then I watch Like
enough and I'm like [ __ ] I'm starting to
like pick [ __ ] up now because all right
kind of like forces your ears to like
foreign
noise after a while if you're just
focusing on the subtitles but like if
you don't have anything there then you
just like oh I know what that word is so
I can kind of draw context
man I I watched Netflix with Japanese
subtitles on but I watch in English I
don't know why I just I've added on I've
just left it I've just left it on oh
okay can you read it fast enough though
no but sometimes I I can read some of
the kanji so it's nice to like practice
just reading it but also sometimes you
see candies that pop up all the time and
you're like oh like if you see the
country but you don't know what it means
yeah no no exactly it's like well I know
what it means but I don't know how to
say it's just reading practice a little
bit for stuff I do know but I I didn't I
don't know why I put it on I just never
turned it off and I'm like because it
doesn't really matter to like click yeah
I realize I feel like I watched the
weirdest [ __ ] at the gym because
everyone in the gym I feel like 50 of
the time they're watching yeah if I'm on
the treadmill oh okay if I'm if I'm like
what I feel like doing a chat right I
just put the thing on the floor really
listen to it okay listen to like the
Netflix documentary oh what that's so
weird I can't do that yeah because like
if I'm if I'm focused yeah I can't focus
when I get super into the show the gym
set kind of like it becomes so easy it
just floats especially for running and
cycling oh no that I get no running at
cycling I understand but like if you're
doing reps and stuff so I'll do the
running watching the documentary I'm
like well I gotta keep watching
I'll go over to the thing and I'm like
yeah he did kill him
but like I actually like Nature
Documentaries like yeah no no no I feel
like I don't know whatever's on Netflix
I have to go into the gym and I have to
make sure that the people on treadmills
aren't watching One Piece because all of
them are watching One Piece oh really
and I'm like I don't want to get spoiled
oh so when I'm running on the treadmill
and I see they're watching One Piece I
have to like I can't like [ __ ] why don't
you watch One Piece as well be part of
the team because because I can I I could
see because I could see Lou foreign
I know it's like seven billion episodes
away but I'm like I just I just saw it
and now I'm gonna think about it all the
time and I'm gonna wait till Luffy
zombies get [ __ ] up for some reason I
don't know what's happening why is it
look like that I don't know I'm gonna
figure out the whole time forget about
something about it let it leave your
brain yeah no to me if I like try to
watch something in the gym or while I'm
doing exercise I will like I've tried
that before and I've watched entire
things I finished my set I'm like I have
no idea what I just watched oh yeah
exits
I think I watched an episode of my hero
yeah that's why that's why I put the
beat here content for the gym uh it's
like I'm not watching like breaking
badge or any of the best TV shows it's
like I'll put the stuff that I'm like
I'll watch but let's throw away things
yeah
AKA Netflix documentaries which are all
the [ __ ] same and it's just like he
was a good boy until he wasn't and then
he killed everything documentary so
[ __ ] bad I'm giving up completely
yeah every now and then there's a
semi-good one yeah but I'm it's not
worth no I agree I agree yeah there was
like way too many episodes too they they
do drag things out a lot more than I
need to and they I swear to God all
these production companies have like
agreed on a format because they're all
the same yeah exactly they're shot the
same they're lit the same the way that
they structure interviews and stuff is
all the same oh did you kind of just
reverse engineer what Netflix expects
and they know they like so they're just
like well if that documentary like five
years ago the exact same way five years
ago is really new and refreshing and it
was cool these documentaries are so cool
no one talks about True Crime on and
then yeah and now everyone everyone on
YouTube everyone on Netflix it's like
it's like these people are waiting for
murders to happen just they have some
new content yeah it's [ __ ] weird so
weird yeah yeah yeah it's like everyone
just saw Tiger King and it's just like
yeah just just do more even before it
was making a Mojo where it all started
oh making them making a murderer just
turned True Crime into like the biggest
goddamn thing and people could not stop
talking about it no one cares now what
but on YouTube it's like there's like a
billion channels that are like today for
your daily dose of murder it's like what
this is so strange how murder of the
week is I I I've mentioned a few times
on the podcast I do feel weird when I
listen to this stuff yeah it's it's hard
to you you listen to it you're like no
it's interesting and then you do sit
back a little bit you're like this is
kind of strange that we're like kind of
doing this for entertainment and we're
kind of there's a way to do it maybe is
there a way to do it but I feel like
I think there's a way to do it
Tastefully but sometimes you can tell
it's like they've just scrolled through
the book of murders and it's been like
no this one will do for this video today
you know what I mean it does feel like
they're kind of just whatever will work
yeah it's not really an interesting
story I always know when a new Mr anime
video comes out because I inevitably get
tagged on it on Twitter you're like oh
the usual clip because okay so what
happened is one of the founding fathers
of anime YouTube
so he ended up
um murdering his entire family
like and uh and so this was like this
was back when anime YouTube was like
just a blip you know 2013. 2013 or
something it was like way before that
it's like literally the start of YouTube
yeah
like I made a video about it at the time
because I was like one of them the
problem
no I made a video being like guys I'm
bothered I'm sad you know because this
this thing happened yeah and then and
then this thing that happened in like
one small community ages ago now is like
being used as like a topic for True
Crime uh and like like the YouTuber I've
noticed that YouTuber that does X thing
a bad thing is like such solid everyone
clicks on it I mean YouTube was arrested
you know it was literally almost viewed
highlight video
we're the problem we're the problems not
even close yeah yeah no I'm do you
remember when content around YouTubers
started to like become a thing because I
remember when it started I was like this
is never why would people want to watch
content about other YouTube
how do you feel about all the people
doing like the history of feelings or
whatever wait who doesn't help people
play Rose to the top
generic videos about it yeah I find it
hard to watch those I don't know why
even though they're usually positive I'm
just like uh I don't like hearing about
myself it feels weird yeah yeah I don't
like an essay format yeah but is that
what you meant oh yeah like that kind of
stuff or they document you or document
your controversies or document anything
it's like um is it just like tiresome I
don't know is it just no another one no
it's more like I don't like watching I
guess you I just feel weird when it's
about yourself you're like I don't yeah
yeah it's weird to watch yeah I mean you
can't get to the number one spot at any
given time and not have people make
videos about you right so yeah you can't
really complain about it yeah yeah I'm
sure I follow like what you mean though
like what type of videos well there's a
lot of channels that like oh when they
get into controversy like the downfall
of oh yeah yeah yeah I don't think I had
no you haven't you haven't had any of
those or maybe they
you know if they if they just document
your history on YouTube and they try and
like tell everyone about your history
and you're like must be weird watching
it from yeah someone who knows yourself
yeah it would feel too weird it's weird
because like like I said it's become
like a massive Trend within the past few
years these videos get millions and
millions of views and yeah yeah I I
people like YouTubers that [ __ ] up they
like watching the best thing yeah love
watching I just think they're doing it
on everyone else
I think they're also just because
they're like such unique case studies
because it's like the way that a
YouTuber [ __ ] up is unlike how any
other celebrity [ __ ] up I mean and and
a lot of the times it's so well
documented I'm like right it's like
celebrity so it's just like oh well then
let's [ __ ] put it in a timeline yeah
make it sound you know have someone to
do that yeah well you choose to [ __ ] up
and they'll be like no absolutely not no
one can associate with them and then R
Kelly will literally like do the worst
thing on earth they'll be like I mean
come on though this song's pretty good
oh I mean it's just like yeah what is
this this is kind of like yeah it is I
think it's just because of the the
that's the thing YouTube is that [ __ ] up
just need to release good it's because
we don't know anything we don't like
fantasize like or like build up
YouTubers in the same way that we do
celebrities right like celebrities are
meant to be like otherworldly there's
supposed to be at our level you know
like Kanye is like insane and does all
this weird stuff and we don't expect
them to act like like a normal person
yeah it's kind of like when you get that
big and like a music or any kind of
thing it's kind of hold them to a
different standard weirdly I don't know
yeah it seems to kind of mellow down
though for both yeah I think so yeah
well the more that social media kind of
yeah crosses more and more and you
realize celebrities say things
they didn't say things before because
they had to go on a talk show and you're
like oh oh they're a flat earther oh I
would never have found that out before
she didn't do that yeah
you're not a glober are you adjusting
yeah the best celebrities are the ones I
usually don't say that much yeah yeah
yeah well I mean you can use private
ones yeah yeah oh that's when they
idolize you the most because you're
mysterious right it's like oh I don't I
don't know what Tom Hanks does he's so
nice when he's in interviews don't ruin
Tom Hanks from
mex's son have you seen the videos of
Tom hanks's son no he was on a channel 5
news that channel where they it was oh
we'll see yeah
yeah a bit of an interesting online
presence oh really
what what's he said
my children will not embarrassing me all
right
gonna happen if you imagine Tom Hanks
Behavior imagine the complete 180 why
does that happen with so many people I I
feel like with a lot of like my
hypothetical child no way yeah it's not
happening well I feel like with a lot of
like celebrity kids they're never gonna
like the kids are never gonna have the
same experience their parents did
because their parents are this Mega like
famous unfortunately would you let your
kids ever go anywhere on camera no oh
Neo camera yeah yeah if you're if your
kid is hypothetical when and if you have
our kids hypothetical children
and if one day they were like Daddy I
want to be a YouTuber [ __ ] no
and he was a bad one
done you're done
stop filming right now yeah this is
trash yeah let me see your metrics right
now
you call these numbers
like give me that Mouse I'll [ __ ]
make your thumbnail for you you're at it
will not do child get rid of it change
it he's like literally eight years old
you disgraced the family name I have
someone on Fiverr like everyone else it
took you two years to get the gold play
button just discipline
the worst part is they'll probably do
like whatever there's 10 times worse
than Tick Tock in the future
in this well what is I just I think
Casey neistat doesn't show his kids face
on camera right would you do that or you
no don't give a [ __ ] you're like that's
like a moral thing isn't it I don't know
I don't know what you do whatever you
when you get there you'll figure it out
I mean tell us right now we need to
scoop right now Felix we gotta get this
children
a lot of babies are ugly right
so does this question depend on if your
kid is beautiful it comes out with like
the Squidward face let me get there so
basically if my baby is [ __ ] gorgeous
asked me if I was an ugly baby I was
like no it was beautiful
how the [ __ ] would you know that but
I've only seen like one cute photo of me
so I'm sure like there's like ugly
babies no I was an ugly baby probably
but that's the thing like you film a
little baby and you put it out there
like yeah
Kobe's the number one YouTuber and being
a pretty baby that's not fair that's
just like you gotta balance it out
somehow are you a humble beginnings like
some stuff that babies do are like kind
of embarrassing and I would not want
that footage of that out there you know
about my baby right yeah yeah I think
that's where I could be worse
I'm just
yeah because I guess that's like the the
weird like moral compass right because
it's like now that now that there's so
many uh like you know YouTubers who are
becoming parents right it's like okay so
I follow the parents who become
YouTubers parents who become YouTube
because they have kids do something yeah
it's like come on make money for me yeah
the [ __ ] clip where that Mum forces
the kids like oh I gotta cry more for
the thumbnail I'm like oh yeah
thumbnail face right now yeah some of
them are so sad like I didn't want to
bring it up yeah there's so many family
vloggers have just gone to [ __ ]
completely yeah I'll remember the whole
[ __ ] daddy 05 situation I I did so
much stupid [ __ ] when I was like eight
to twelve even to 16 honestly yeah like
I just can't imagine if my mum filmed it
and put it online like I once was I was
I was playing the Pokemon trading card
game with my Game Boy SP another one of
the yeah yeah I know I was I was just
peeing and I dropped it in the toilet
right while I was peeing because I was
literally pissing while playing it so
addictive what's your posture if you
drop it in there I'm standing standing
pissing playing it dropped it inside
and he was even embarrassing enough
because my parents wouldn't stop telling
people who we met that I I was peeing
and I dropped my Game Boy and as a kid
this was like soul-crushing oh yeah of
course and I was like what if my parents
did this it would be like the thumbnail
be oh drop Game Boy
pushing yourself and you dropped it in
the toilet reenacting yeah I'd be like
out of the toilet we'll get the
thumbnail shot right I genuinely think I
would get like trauma yeah I'd get like
PTSD or something exactly it wouldn't be
like a normal functioning human being
yeah all right like okay say say we all
have kids right at what age would you be
like if your kid comes to you and goes
dad I want to be an influencer or a tick
tocker or a YouTuber whatever at what
age is it just like okay you're old
enough go go for your dreams I'd say
like
sixteen sixteen yeah like to the point
where it's like because it's like
anything younger than that it's like
they don't know
so you need to you need to have like I
feel like to be a successful uh YouTuber
anything like that you just need to like
grow up with the internet and like and
be involved in like the yeah be on the
viewing side for a while so that you can
like you know understand it from the
viewing position yeah I was always
addicted to being online yeah yeah yeah
I couldn't 100 couldn't get me off yeah
but like you see these YouTubers were
like you know 13 12 years old and I'm
just like how are you like functioning
right now because it's all for them yeah
because it's like I didn't know what the
[ __ ] I was doing when I was 12 13 years
old and it's like and now you're you
have a million eyes on you yeah that's
[ __ ] weird it's like that would be
terrifying yeah and I also don't want to
be you know I don't want the situation
of like my [ __ ] 12 year old coming to
me being like Dad so of people are
saying mean things on the internet and
like what the only thing I can say is
you're weak
Ness upload that's that's all that just
delete the comment bro you'll be all
right you might actually make a monster
as well who just like can't be like
criticized and he just doesn't accept
anything because he's been taught from
like age 12 to ignore everything
everyone says online yeah just what do
you mean I have to do whatever I want
I'd be like telling my kid off and it'd
be like I've heard worse on my comments
dad you fell off your channel I'm not
listening to you yeah
what about what about the age you'd
first allow them to like upload the
first video they're not uploading any
videos
unless they unless they like you know if
they want to make it really good if they
want to be like a filmmaker or make [ __ ]
it's like go ahead but I'm gonna make
sure they don't yeah when you were kids
like but anything else yeah like Xbox
gameplay no audio or anything I used to
put up [ __ ] on like deviantART back in
the day hell yeah is it still up yeah
did you really still want that I got a
seat
the anime
manager now thankfully someone's gonna
I probably must have been 16. wait wait
so you've been watching anime since
you're like 16. I think so yeah I
thought you got into it when you were
like 20 something
no
um I think I think uh yeah I got into it
maybe yeah how did you find that yeah
how did you find out about anime yeah uh
my friend was really into it and he got
me oh yeah yeah what song what song did
you choose for your death note AMV let
me guess was it Lincoln yeah we got to
take a guess yeah
I was I was trying to find it like I
searched YouTube and like upload date
like 10 years
what compelled you to make it definitely
I thought it was [ __ ] cool it was
dope I showed it to my mom and
everything I'm like Mom check one out
check out Windows Movie Maker as a
parent you must be pretty impression of
your kid makes anything you're like wow
you did something yeah you don't do
anything you normally just sit around
and annoy me like this yeah the first
video my mom saw she was just like wow
you speak English what the [ __ ]
she didn't know I guess no wait that
must be so trippy would your kid just
knew a language you're like what the
[ __ ] because I learned like from talking
to people online just gaming and stuff
yeah well it's crazy because your accent
is like I mean just not really that
Swedish no it's kind of weird yeah
neutralized accent that's [ __ ] awful
so you learn via gamer lingo yeah I
guess so oh my God yeah because I always
notice when you play games in EU right
you always used to play online yeah and
you would just be like oh yeah I'm 12
from Norway I've post
I've been playing games since I was like
two that's why and it's just like what
the [ __ ] is going on in these countries
but then every every single kid from the
Netherlands is just fluent by it yeah
did you learn like lead speak back in
the day oh [ __ ] yeah oh yeah yeah that
was great yeah much
uh we would play DotA the most yeah
why are you cringing
but it's it's like everything like this
thing the first thing that comes out is
[ __ ] and the the second thing that comes
out afterwards fixes it makes it good
damn it have you watched uh it's like
the DOTA movie versus Arcane it's like
Arcane is good have you watched Arcane
no I haven't [ __ ] you should watch our
game hey everyone told me to watch this
shut up I'm not watching yeah exactly
there are literally two of them now
you betrayed the cause
I thought if anyone could bully Joe into
watching it it'd be you no
he's got my back I'm never watching it
now
just as bad as him God [ __ ] Dad yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] back in the day because in
Sweden we've got a net cafes and we
would just play that you're only going
to try it we never had net cafes in the
UK and it was like this like really
exotic idea like you can go to like a
cafe I wanted to open one in UK because
I'm like the kids need to experience
this it's really high it's pretty fun
it's [ __ ] so good but I don't see
people with you now yeah I think they
still would I think still going back in
the day you couldn't play online the
same it's the whole idea of like land
parties back in the day right yeah it
was the high part yeah the first time I
ever went to one was in Ireland really
it was like in the middle of nowhere and
it was when uh COD zombies was a really
big thing oh [ __ ] man this dude had
installed like all the modded maps on
the PC and it's the first time I found
out that you could make like maps that
weren't the original yeah what the [ __ ]
what the hell and then the little kids
were like just shouting at the guy
around the shop I'm like give me more
time for free and for some reason he did
I don't know how play stayed in business
my house was always the hub for land
parties because yeah well because my dad
was like you know working in Tech right
so he's just like yeah I'll set it off
for you I've got the 30 meter Land
Camera
so we had like Civ two land parties I
was like Dad can you install the the
Wi-Fi thing on the Xbox 360 and you'd be
like nah later
my dad didn't know what we were doing
but he was like yeah I can set up a land
thing what the [ __ ]
don't have that experience how deep in
How deep did you get into Halo I was
like addicted to Halo when I got it
because when my Xbox came with Halo 3.
oh okay and so I was just like obsessed
with Halo did you ever join any like
Clans or something online or stuff like
that yeah I did you did oh dude I
actually uh actually like like convinced
these Swedish people to like help me win
a competition one time I mean what so so
okay so there's this thing back in the
day when I used to win a bunch of uh
like one modern warfare three came out
I've explained this on the podcast I was
so [ __ ] addicted to Modern Warfare
three they had this thing no too was
really good do you ever play three much
or you got out okay so I got out of this
game so three three came out and they
introduced this thing called like Call
of Duty Elite who are you paid like I
don't know like 40 pounds or 40 euros
something for it that's like a deal and
you could you get all the DLC as they
always did right they will come out but
you could do these online tournaments
where you could play online and uh you
could win like physical prizes so you
could win like a Jeep or a quad bike or
an iPad I want like an iPad I wanna I
want an iPad I want a bunch of cool
stuff I was really [ __ ] good at Parts
all right so I wanted to win uh this one
price and a lot of people started
teaming up even though you're supposed
to only do it like you and the idea was
you going to a public Lobby and like
capture the most flags right so the way
you would do it is that like uh you know
you would if you did like the game kill
confirmed remember this game no will you
kill someone to pick up the tags I
didn't remember that yeah you would be
like hey go and kill the kill and don't
pick it up and I'll collect them all oh
yeah stuff like that okay so
so right for some reason Swedish Danish
and Norwegian people were always nutty
at COD like that was like the thing in
the European service right it was always
the Norwegian people playing FPS yeah
yeah that's right you just get destroyed
by someone click on their banner and it
would just be in like like the Norwegian
language which is just like what I don't
know what this is
gonna be Norwegians
yeah so anyway I'd want to watch these
tournaments right and then I was trying
to get people to help me out but I
wanted really good people and it was
these a group of these Swedish kids that
were like I don't know we were all like
15 16 I was like I'll join your clan if
you help me win these tournaments
you were that desperate for you because
they want it because they wanted to be
like we had a top player on our team oh
okay I was like I'll join your clan if
you help me win this tournament there's
nothing in it for them they would have
they were literally helping me get an
iPad okay and so these Swedish kids were
just like helping me get this thing and
we that's poor Swedish mind manipulation
they were we were all too good though
where the the tournament looks so stupid
because the after all the results came
out it was like me and then second place
was ridiculously far away and so a bunch
of the comments were like what the [ __ ]
this guy oh really yeah so then I got
banned after it but I still got my iPad
I still got my iPad
thanks shout out to those Swedish kids
that I caught a scam Sweden you guys are
great free labor
listen if Minecraft has taught me
anything it's a kids want to do Free
Labor dude I mean come on
they want to be worked they the children
yearn for the minds nowadays think about
it
maybe we should bring it back
it's a slavery exists if it's virtual I
don't know
child labor it's different it's
different hey if I have to pay for them
I'm kidding I'm kidding uh gotta get
some gifts I see each other yes trying
to trying to one-up Jack I see Jack
didn't bring his gifts he didn't no he
didn't well then of course I wanted
what do you mean well because because
you mentioned when we were getting Jack
on you like you bastards why are they
getting Jack on before me yeah the
[ __ ] that was such a [ __ ] yeah it
was actually a little salty why we were
gonna get you one eventually because I
met up with you guys three years ago and
you were like we're gonna do a podcast
really because I'm like
and then I'm like cool I'll be a guest
six nine we're saying yeah episode six
and that was like episode ten we're like
wow that's very uh camping in the UK and
like a [ __ ] nothing
it's funny because when you said like oh
come on I'm like episode 69 I'm just
like Felix doesn't want to come on
because we're never gonna reach episode
16 yeah
wow you're really positive about this
[ __ ] podcast reaching 69 episodes
is it PewDiePie merch
that's why I said
I got you some whiskey
you know this one yeah this is really
nice is it actually it's very nice
whiskey I've I've been terrible with
whiskey so I'm perfect
just like you one of your favorites uh
yeah it's one of my favorite it's a bit
different because it's uh aged in the
forest by the way oh wow water it's got
a bit different flavor what's the
preferred way of drinking this would you
recommend just
straight straight yeah
I don't know I don't know whiskey you
can get those like whiskey like Stone
cubes yeah I use those I feel like I
have to get into whistles
thank you very much I appreciate it yeah
this is awesome yeah
whiskey glass that has like a small
opening so you can smell it and then
okay I'll have to ask you what those are
off to get something I don't have any
good whiskey glasses Joey yeah I wanted
to give you my favorite Radiohead album
which was in rainbows oh [ __ ] I couldn't
get it so I got you my favorite cigaross
album oh [ __ ] yeah yeah we got I
actually don't have this one yet I know
we also have to blow the cover yeah yeah
hell yeah I actually don't have this one
yet I Aki you showed me your collection
oh really
smart and smart [ __ ] yeah thanks so much
it's a good one yeah I love this album
I think all our guests
by the way yeah okay yeah so I'm glad
you didn't get it yeah oh god what have
you got for gone yeah
uh yeah it's a bit cringe isn't it
I've never seen like I never knew about
this until you started getting I've seen
it I just thought it was like a thing
people do on YouTube yeah like the
corners what is it is it Counter Strike
but people have the knives
three years later how the [ __ ] do you do
it what's the like technique yeah uh
uh yeah yeah you you just fiddle like
whatever you want with it that's so sick
[ __ ] that
it's kind of like pen spinning in a
sense yeah yeah that's that's why like
I've seen Felix do it I'm like I could
get into this yeah because you can paint
spins yeah yeah oh my God he's never
gonna put it down all right it's better
if I don't keep it that's so sick it's
fun fiddling tool basically you like
fiddle that's yeah this is this is why
like the whole reason I learned how to
spin a pen was because I'm gonna fiddle
let's at least make it look cool so now
that you got me this I'm like [ __ ] you
can't watch anything yeah yeah I just
like fiddle with along with this guy
that's fine thank you so much yeah these
gifts are [ __ ] awesome yeah thank you
again oh yeah thank you nice that's so
nice oh yeah all right so my turn yeah
have you seen by the way I don't know I
it was sure like top anime if you had to
give like list off some of your
favorites uh
ah favorite we're obliged to talk to you
about anime yeah
foreign
I gotta think a second uh favorite
watch recently
are you a little more of an anime watch
or a mongerators yeah no I watch anime
yeah uh
[ __ ]
why is definitely the only thing
it's a great [ __ ] show it's like it's
a really good show how did I spill this
all the way down I don't know how do
they do that I remember watching Naruto
back in the day and I was like no one
else knows about Naruto It's like
because no one was watching it outside
yeah it was so underground yeah it was I
felt so cool watching that like yo this
is this is some drugs nobody has ever
watched Naruto
no it doesn't exist I had so much uh
yeah it anime felt underground back in
the day yeah somebody like I was yeah
yeah I remember Clannad was the [ __ ]
good [ __ ] well actually like one of my
favorite video of yours is the one where
you talked about blam um
that's a really good one
it was so out there because I'm like
wait Felix reads manga and also it's
blam yeah
huh you're like yeah I really like lamb
too but like no one really talks about
it it's really like yeah underground
yeah that's a truly underground one yeah
is it really yeah I feel like the
longest time I confused blaming against
together I don't know
sci-fi you know very gritty dancers a
ride Gantz is a [ __ ] ride dude yeah
he dances
I don't want to see that I mean in
Japanese is pronounced
yeah diamonds are really good that's
probably my favorite manga I made a
video yeah too busy watch making amvs to
watch out of things
honestly I missed I missed the AMV eras
so much no I don't know like that should
pop off with like Tick Tock and [ __ ]
like that yeah I mean yeah it's like
what they [ __ ] take Breaking Bad
clips and put some [ __ ] music over it
and they're like epic Walter White
moment yeah and it's just like boom boom
because I'm Heisenberg born boy I said
what the [ __ ] is this because like I
don't even call it AMV anymore this it's
just edits here's Anatomy yeah
yeah because like most of the time it's
the same it's this like not saying
they're not like talented editors but
most of the time it looks exactly the
same you take like you take a scene from
anime you uh put it through this uh you
put it through the 60 FPS filter you
know so it looks super smooth yeah and
then you zoom into the eye and then it's
like and then you do like the time the
12 transition
like gaussian blur 100 just every yeah
in the background yeah yeah oh the
Nightcore oh the Nightcore here God I
don't miss the Nightcore era
I still listening [ __ ] off that's my
work I'm using
no you don't Owl City Nightcore I'm I'm
curious because you've been on YouTube
so long do you have like a favorite
YouTube era
favorite YouTuber where you think
YouTube was the most interesting or
anything like the type of content that
used to be really hard but you don't
really hear about anymore kind of uh
I don't know what like
defines YouTube era but I do remember
there was like before before YouTube
made uh the adpocalypse
[ __ ] Joe Rogan a lot of people always
played it it wasn't me you're like yes
it wasn't me I swear no it was it was it
aligned at a time it was the wild west
of YouTube
what the rules were just talking about
like the filthy Frankie or yeah it was
gonna happen it was going to happen yeah
unfortunately you were the biggest name
at the time
yeah
it's like every time my video gets
demonetized I'm like Felix
oh my [ __ ] god is means that must be
frustrating I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
people still believe it like genuinely
yeah it's been ever well it was like a
common thing at the time
but yeah it was because of extremist
videos online oh yeah yeah it was like
some of the [ __ ] that was getting like
insane address it was insane yeah yeah
even then it's still not great I regret
answering this question
I remember though when Not only was it
like the YouTube filthy Frank era but
there was the PewDiePie
good times you just like kind of you
know change your voice yeah
I remember being in because I jumped in
bright the Brighton water and yeah we
were out on a boat and I was wearing
fully clothed in it I was just like well
I hope I can swim back
okay luckily I made it back but it was
just so uh it was an ultimate timeline
where you just died yeah
I would happily die there that was peak
of YouTube it was it was great
everything's like so polished now yeah
like every everyone is either like
trying to copy Mr Beast yeah that's a
whole section of YouTube that is a whole
video I I do you know Mr Beast I think
does really interesting things but the
it's so interesting seeing the people
who make videos about Mr Beast or trying
to get his attention which is such a
weird genre of YouTube now yeah I made
the biggest cardboard cut out of Mr
Beast and to get his attention and I'm
gonna do it right now
exactly the same and they all all sound
indistinguishable it's so bizarre it's
like they're all going for the same
genre and it's like what happened to
like telling a story or you know just
having a paste to a video you know just
having a flow the stories that they give
this thing together
you can't tell a story that builds up
like nicely it's like you have to throw
it oh yeah
yeah it is this this era of just
screaming do it do everything in five
seconds or you fell off plus ratio
you're irrelevant it's like whoa and the
phone and like the style and everything
you know I I feel like you can I'll do a
lot of interesting things and get good
views without needing to scream and
shot things really fast how do you guys
feel about the subtitling of every word
per second and shorts
but for actual videos I hate it
just have like actual subtitles like the
BBC has a has a guideline for
recommended subtitles
no it's like a it's like a yellow tax
black box it's like is it the perfect
spacing timing it also looks [ __ ]
ugly yeah that's no I think it looks
really nice
you know readability but obviously I
think that subtitles should be you know
yeah it's like you should have them turn
on if you want I don't like the idea of
a 20 minute video it is kind of annoying
sometimes one word and every word
changes it's like at least have a line I
used to do that way back in the day yeah
oh that was the thing yeah yeah of
course like my top funniest moment
videos I was like
painfully editing all the subtitles took
[ __ ] forever you did the subtitles
yeah and I was like well it's always
been a wave it's an artificial way of
adding more like energy yeah yeah
because you by doing it you just inject
energy well what is it like the the
gaming people like the oh the whole crew
like they always have every word like
subtitle as well right yeah I could
never make my editors do that no I feel
like 12 seconds hate subtitling normally
let alone subtitles every single one
it's horrible because you listen to the
audio and you're like I think I said
that listen again oh no it's wrong
hard spacings off yeah drag okay it's
just like especially especially with
these like you know people who are kind
of you know biting off the Mr Beast like
formula they all talk so [ __ ] fast as
well so it's like you can't even see the
words it's cool it's like two frames of
work yeah you're right it's pretty
bizarre how you just there's a whole
genre of kind of like mimicking this one
YouTube it didn't really happen before
uh because you know I mean but it's just
so big and it's always happened with
like some of the you know big not this
one
at the time but then I realized yeah no
it's fine everyone that's cool yeah but
I feel like confuse each other at some
point yeah but I also feel like back in
that time like all you had to do was
just like play the same game that you
wanted yeah
well the thing
spend so much time trying to find like
indie horror games yeah right so if you
found one that was like really cool and
then seeing everyone else has played the
day after you're just like ah come on
yeah let me enjoy it for a dance let me
have my success I found it I don't know
to me it took a lot of time to find
stuff so I was just like oh cool someone
just stole what I did but now I do it
all the time oh yeah YouTube YouTube is
about finding someone else's thing and
be like I'm gonna make that better
I'm gonna do that but just twist it a
little bit literally the entirety of
YouTube yeah at the time I thought that
that was the case but no yeah that's why
when someone you know like Mr Beast
comes on with it like does something
completely new everyone's like okay I
guess that's the more Yeah the more
people do it the better for everyone
anyway so yeah yeah yeah I remember when
I found Slender the first time oh my
gosh this is gonna be huge I found it
that's the first one I remember I even
checked if anyone's ever played this
game before and literally no one had
played it oh my God that sounds crazy
yeah that was so big Terry how many
views did your video get on it like
something stupid right I don't know but
that was fun fun times for me at least
but I mean that just like opened the
floodgates
oh my God yeah I can't stand horror
games anymore I just can't do it I hate
them I'm surprised you lasted that long
playing horror games because like you
you always said from the beginning you
didn't like playing horror games no
you're right yeah yeah yeah and like you
went through some of the [ __ ] wildest
[ __ ] hard games and it's like well
like you know back in like 2013 2014
when you know I was watching you yeah
whereas just like this is the most
terrifying [ __ ] [ __ ] ever how does
this guy do it for a living
that's cool yeah yeah I mean I couldn't
do that because I remember like I think
you were one of the first ones who like
brought out like the Jeff the Killer
game right and like those kinds of
things right well you know
which games they played I don't know
yeah okay you might have found a lot of
Japanese influence from there right
because a lot of the Indie horos are
Japanese
oh like the RPG Maker you're the RPG
Maker games oh yes you're right
yeah that one was huge all the other
ones that were really big it was really
good yeah it was good oh [ __ ] that's
those are great games as well yeah have
you played many games recently that you
thought were really really good or any
games of recent that released
that's not worth it I played Magic the
Gathering Arena do you like inscription
yeah I know I like it yeah
it's pretty my favorite game it's like a
rogue like card thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh even I've heard of that one yeah
the reviews are insane I've heard it
I've heard it's really good yeah again
it's one of those games don't look
anything yet don't look at anything just
play it it's amazing you won't regret it
that's good yeah yeah I'm so glad I went
to it not know nothing it's one of the
best games I've ever played in my life
I'm a lot of building games they're Road
likes that building games are so fun
you'll enjoy the spider then I'll play
inscription you play say the Spire all
right deal deal all right okay we gotta
do it all right
yeah that was really good I enjoyed
Hades a lot too Hades was so good [ __ ]
the soundtrack went so hard in that game
so good I didn't I didn't listen to any
of the story though I was kind of like
yeah whatever I like that they talk way
too much in that game watch out
honestly I remember watching I don't
know what [ __ ] episode you guys were
talking about skipping cutscenes or [ __ ]
like that or like kind of early
stuff yeah
yes yes
I don't have time for this [ __ ] I want
to play a game oh [ __ ] yes oh my God
but it's so funny because I'm like I'm
not the only one yeah
when I stream I stream the game and
people are like stop
casting he gets so mad and I'm like bro
it sucks the story sucks
how are you on no one's side today
I had these right I uh that that
cutscene was so [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
gonna talk to everyone
I hate games you can't be that
interesting
you get more and must in the world
is insanely fast-paced game yeah
and then it's like go and talk to
Achilles go and go and talk to Hercules
and it's like no and I don't want to do
this nine times again it's like I'll
kill my my dad and I'll be done with it
do you have you played God of War no
I I'd be interesting to see what it
makes their cutscenes yeah because it's
yeah they do it well I then there's some
games yeah yeah it's such a smooth
transition between gameplay and cutscene
yeah yeah I would be interested to hear
your opinion actually in Elder ring you
cut the cutscene there wasn't really
many cut scenes I did Skip some though I
was kind of because I I tell people that
yeah I cut the I skipped the cutscenes
you missed the guy moaning in the start
the opening oh yeah he goes oh that's so
good there was an edit it was like just
the moaning from the Elden ring intro
but the thing is I say that I skipped
the cutscene xandering they're like oh
okay yeah that's normal I'm like
but the first time
they come like mid boss it's kind of
like marked up playing this boss I'm
like [ __ ] yeah half health and then I'm
like I'm just gonna sit and watch a
movie no
I refuse some animals
okay I am firmly on your side however
mid boss cutscenes little hype but I'm
hyped up at that point bro voice actors
are crying okay okay I'm a voice actor
it's cool whatever uh I think that in
the Elden ring right you know the boss
where you fight the uh the snake in the
the blood uh area yeah yeah see what
happens I know they're cool
you just go on YouTube
[ __ ] amazing so good that was he you
need to finish it I do I will you know
what I'll do I'll do on the tour yeah
with those games so I kind of like being
kind of lost and not knowing what the
[ __ ] going on no it's perfect for not
looking at guides it's great yeah having
chat back seat you sometimes are so
annoying but even with the lore like I
kind of know
come on
I'm Mexican
they just made [ __ ] up I'm like I don't
know what the [ __ ] is happening
too yeah yeah you know wash people in it
yeah it is yeah
so I'm guessing you don't play many
story based games then I used to I think
I played too many and now I can't see
yeah I enjoy that I don't have the
pictures anymore I don't know goopy game
of goblin Brave
I think I noticed when you play too many
games you just you just
a lot of the time I'm like the cutscene
is not gonna enhance or like my
enjoyment so I just skip it I don't give
a [ __ ] I'm just like whatever get on
with it I don't care let me [ __ ] play
the game like for me it's all gameplay
that's where I get the enjoyment out of
and like the gameplay Loop and if that's
solid yeah that's real gaming movies
yeah
I like the dressing I like that movie
watches
I like story I like characters and stuff
I play Final Fantasy and they're
watching cutscenes half the God damn
yeah and they're [ __ ] great no love
them
have you played a visual novel
I I have I have places
oh yeah every YouTuber played the
picture yeah back in the day whoa It's
pigeon The Corpse Party oh yeah sorry he
loved that one that's funny
yeah I like that one actually yeah that
was huge on YouTube yeah yeah I feel
like I feel like YouTube or like game
Villas went through a phase where some
game developers literally made games for
YouTubers oh yeah yeah oh yeah
definitely I think that's like still
kind of a thing always sucks yeah I like
your fiddling already
you know how I feel like you know like
when a kid's annoying you like here's
your Game Boy go in the corner and play
by yourself this is this is just me
right now with this you know it's just
like I'll just let's go I'm just gonna
be playing with this I'm curious do you
console gamer or PC games PC games
yeah that's what we're gonna do without
alarms yeah we'd almost have PC counters
these guys are more console yeah oh
that's cringe
that's why we that's why we cut the
cutscene yeah
what do you mean on water cooled kill
yourself bro
anymore yeah
yeah why would you do that if I have a
choice I 100 choose console really yeah
the only time my game on PC is a film on
streaming that's it yeah you can just
plug in the controller to a lot of games
and then it runs even better than it
does on the TV makes no sense oh because
I love gaming on the phone
I hate gaming on in front of my computer
yeah
because I want to be comfortable
I can play music I can I could yeah I
can do that on the couch you want to
just sit back relax on the couch
sometimes you just want to like you know
sink in a bit more yeah you gotta get a
gamer chair and I hate it
it can even do this I still want it
before my couch yeah no you want to be
focused as a gamer you guys are sloppy
Gamers I can tell now you play these
slow ass games sitting on your account
yeah they're great yeah I play games to
relax
that's relaxing he's like oh yeah I'm
relaxed with my 120 [ __ ] beats per
minute heart rate I like it was not
relaxing yeah it was relaxing when you
when you've got a little too op and went
to an area oh yeah that was scared and
you're like yeah
that was fun that was so good and then
you get then you go to the bosses again
yeah
I beat it with that dang
did you actually do that yeah
wait what the whole game yeah how long
did that take you clearly haven't
watched my video
but I thought it was like a meme no I
actually like a meme no death run come
click the stream I did I [ __ ] did it
patronize
you I worked hard for that I don't need
a knife how about this Felix Persona 5
play through no skip cutscene no skip
The Impossible difficulty
real achievement right there what about
uh
in Elton ring I just I died 90 of the
time to [ __ ] falling yeah how do you
not do that you have to plan your route
exactly oh my God are you like does your
map at all yes I do yeah because it
would take too long too otherwise you
had to really figure out that did you
did you do the do you know when you in
Alden ring there's a section where you
can go to like the fire people what do
they call the fire pyromancers no no the
um
bad ending in Elden ring where you
accept the like fire into you oh yeah
you have to jump down all of those
things did you do that no you have to
jump down this horrible like jump
king-esque section really of like oh
yeah I've seen that yeah no I'm you
avoid those you have to do like precise
platforming right on Elden ring in a
[ __ ] Souls game in a Souls game
precise platforming I love that part
didn't you it was like it was very jump
King and meets Alden right now I did it
oh it was it took me like four hours and
I died like 500 times I lost all my
money there was no point even like
having an attachment to it uh I could
not get it yeah
please play jumping no no no no no no no
no why not tell me this already I'm not
playing that's the perfect game for you
there's no you're like yeah there's no
cutscene there's no cutscenes no
cutscenes no story actually there is I
played it it's not good what
I'm pretty sure it's Swedish or some
[ __ ] too I don't know you guys make good
games right Minecraft you're like oh yes
yeah I don't know I know I wouldn't like
it too much and I'm not gonna do it so
well jumping yeah okay let's get it
this is pure stuff it's really good it's
really one of my favorite games
genuinely I believe it
yeah exactly exactly I'm still a bit
stuck on this console versus pixie thing
because I I don't get it
what do you mean
a bottle of this if you have gaming
computers why would you not play on them
because I hate sitting in front of my
computer playing games everything does
run better and it looks much better it's
cleaner you can do other [ __ ] don't
really care okay do you subscribe
because these guys just don't believe it
I'm like I think the better
higher refresh rate monitors are like
amazing yeah they look so good yeah and
they just think I'm talking out of my
ass and I'm like I think you guys have
been brainwashed to be honestly it's so
much difference I bought one just
because this guy wouldn't shut up and I
tried and I'm like there's no [ __ ]
difference yeah yeah I made sure he's
like he's like there's no for me just
just for the fail safe and I play it's
like there's no difference what are you
talking about playing professional novel
of course is that no just like like I
tried every like all sorts of different
games
I like moved it over to my other monitor
just to see the difference and I'm like
there's no [ __ ] have you talked about
this on the podcast yeah yeah
I've ever heard because these both agree
with it and I'm here alone being like
they're like I'm a clown and it's like
no way none of the games I play is like
no chance
the games that I'm playing right even
like RuneScape looks better in 144hz
like he goes way smoother it is what
everything even run at 144. you never
just like grabbed the window and you'd
swirl it around like ah so close
I do that yeah it's satisfying
finish
es
is this like a gamer fetish like I heard
it's a refresh rate
because to me it's like how can you not
it's like it's like I it's like having a
rock for a mouse and then going to an
actual Mouse it's like so much
difference oh my God all right but okay
go going back to console versus PC yeah
okay all right okay okay they can't win
right okay look I I won a game on like a
big TV I want to put my feet up yeah you
can't just have like a massive [ __ ]
monitor right you can't just have a TV
I used to have an ultra wide or you have
three monitors or two right I got three
yeah there you go I just want one big
monitor which is the TV
yeah but I also watch movies and films
on and an anime and I just sit back in
my comfort zone put my feet up for media
gaming is
gaming is literal media I want one
monitor that's a TV that's so good yeah
you can plug it into your computer yeah
I've had a friend who had a PC in his
living room and just hooked it I mean
you could plug it into your computer but
at that point it's just a [ __ ] hassle
because like you know you [ __ ] got a
login and you gotta like load up again
yeah I just want to press one button
games there all right I can game I can
game yeah I want to relax we got Gamers
too okay console gamers are Gamers too
we're tired of being oppressed
these boys have like the top of the line
PCS yeah that's the thing I understand
like well that's just privilegation
related only reporting a console but
like once you get to that PC stage
There's No Going Back you gotta Taste of
sweet Heaven I don't know man I agree I
mean I'm PC for days I fully believe
this is like a fish just like it's like
it's like when they Port games to like
mobile I'm like don't don't yeah don't
okay no I'm not that psychotic where I'm
like Yay on mobile but like you know I
mean I guess yeah I get it but I'm also
that guy who's just like I see something
in 1080 and I see something in 4k and
I'm like there's a difference but also I
don't care I don't really care that much
you know that's why it's weird because I
do agree with that but gaming is so
different I think that's a question
there's definitely a noticeable
difference okay so how you feel about
the difference between 1080 and 4K is
how I feel good
okay there's a difference but it's not
remarkable
I'm like does it enhance my game
experience not really
that's what I'm saying it has to be a
finish no no it's not it's not fetishize
it yeah it is it's genuinely it's
genuinely Gamers will do this and be
like oh
that's okay you're not a gamer oh
if that doesn't make me a gamer then I'm
not a game all right we need to find
Middle Ground here because it's getting
a little yeah this is trash types
you've watched enough
I don't like being part of it I like
watch it
I guess Fearless is never coming back
with trash taste to live up to what you
thought it was gonna be really fun yeah
well now that you live here you can come
back anytime yeah because I'm sure our
comments are gonna be just [ __ ] like
what I'm looking forward to the next
time he's on 600 episodes later oh yeah
we should do it yeah this is gonna be a
comment [ __ ] Minefield I could
already tell oh my God
[ __ ] sake
lovely Pages oh my God which Patron is
your favorite Felix point at it this is
weird being part of this names yeah
you're already there now I like this guy
yeah yeah hell yeah that guy that guy
hey if you'd like to join the patreon
and support the show then go over to
patreon.com
because I was laughing at something I
thought about oh it was it was when you
guys were [ __ ] on uh subscription
models
it made me laugh so hard I'm like holy
[ __ ]
you're up to date
yeah I think it's one of the most recent
trash days
I really appreciated that it's like no
selfie
Twitter sentences in the subreddit if
you interface listen to us on Spotify
and uh yeah go check out this dude you
know I like I just realized I don't
think we ever introduced we don't need
to but I don't think we ever did that's
like that's like having the pope on
being like don't introduce yourself just
in case there you go we'll see you guys
next week bye Earth